[Musique]
votre plan de mission celui que
nous avons côtoyé capitaine
faites-le tuer le chef ses combats
n'étant pas longs les garçons de jamais ici
encore six de notre première et dernière option
en matière de flèches de talent ces hommes
sont les meilleurs dans ce qu'ils font  et ça
fait de mauvaises choses le gras Desert Shield de
retour dans le
jeu ne vous y trompez pas bien que nous soyons en guerre et
nous ne manquerons pas de
monter dans le camion manger à nouveau c'est ce que nous
devons faire Je n'ai pas le choix pense que je
connais le garçon Davis  est prêt à dire sa première
fois pour le pays du coton, tu
vas laisser ça derrière
moi
[Musique]
- Todd et le pays ne peuvent s'empêcher de se demander
peut-être que Dieu nous pardonnera pour ce que nous avons
fait